[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à sept autres
éditions dc espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie yvon nous allons
parler cette semaine d'un sujet très
sensible
un sujet difficile mais un sujet
incontournable puisque nous sommes hélas
j'ai le g2 rhume alors je vais essayer
de garder la voie la plus claire
possible pendant tout le long de
l'émission
mais nous sommes la semaine nationale de
la prévention du suicide
pour en parler deux personnes très
intéressantes alors en studio avec nous
le docteur stanley vollant bonjour dans
leur volant coup et ellis queen notre
chroniqueuse bonjour relish sur les
pontons et mairie et puis à québec nous
avons une invitée elle s'appelle valérie
veine lé congrès hier en crise sociale
et violence familiale à la commission de
la sécurité et des services sociaux des
premières nations du québec et du
labrador quand on n'a pas de voix c'est
très long à dire bonjour madame veine
coup et bonjour cauet bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors vous nous voyez
comme on vous voit alors c'est très bien
nous allons pouvoir converser au cours
des prochaines minutes
on va parler évidemment de ce qui est
mis en place dans les communautés et
puis on va témoigner aussi de ce qu est
que de se rapprocher du suicide parce
que docteur volant ça a été votre cas
vous vous êtes rapprocher du suicide
à quelques reprises de façon très
personnelle j'ai vécu en 2007 lors d'une
séparation j'ai fait une dépression et
le cadre de ma dépression quelques
semaines après j'ai plus fusil et gelé
mis dans la bouche et j'étais sur le
point de tirer sur la gâchette et
ferment dans les écrits je devais faire
pour mes écrits des yeux j'avais oublié
un paragraphe puis à ce moment là
j'avais un blackberry et un toujours un
bouton il y avait un bouton send essaye
de l'est comme ça et vega mini miss et
vimont mon texte et j'ai fait scène par
erreur et chose est mon ami qui est un
agent du même lot reçu immédiatement
parce que ça commençait par la phrase
suivante louis quand on recevra le email
je suis mort rappelle la police près ce
mot n'atterrisse je suis leur expliquer
le pourquoi et le comment c'est pas
arrivé je suis très content aujourd'hui
et je peux témoigner que ma ville le les
pressions des fois les passants de
marché dans la noirceur de marché à la
plus grande des noirs ça la plus froide
la plus longue mais le salut fis
toujours pas retiré et il s'est levé
pour moi ç'a pris du temps
j'ai des gens qui m'a accompagné qui
m'ont tenu la main à travers cette
longue nuit qui m'a paru interminable et
aujourd'hui
onze ans après j'ai encore vivant et je
fais du bien au monde et je sauve des
personnes et aujourd'hui même jeudi à
j'ai appris que comme un ami très proche
est dans une grande détresse et je viens
de
je dois lui parler après midi donc juive
personnellement un événement très très
proche encore dû céder le suicide je les
ai vécus à plusieurs reprises à travers
mes marche des gens qui m'ont parlé de
leur expérience
il nous met chez nous cette longue
marche de kw à 6000 km que vous avez
fait là au cours des dernières années
oui ça vous a permis d'aller à la
rencontre de jeunes qui avaient
peut-être justement ce genre d'idées
noires énormément je pense que cela
cesse et qu'on parle de 40% des
autochtones qui auraient des idées
noires des suicidaires
ce qui est nettement supérieur à la
moyenne canadienne mais de façon
personnelle de façon biaisée peut-être
les gens qui viennent me voir peut-être
c'est des gens qui avaient des
problématiques je voudrais une grande
grande majorité des gens auront exprimé
avoir passé à travers des périodes très
très noir et penser au souci donc pour
moi - échantillonnage personnel c'est de
60 à 80 pour ça des gens et ça remonte
mais je pense que c'est peut-être la
pointe de l'iceberg d'un phénomène qui
est beaucoup plus important c'est le
traumatisme trans-générationnel que nos
vécus depuis la colonisation
les pensionnaires la violence dans nos
communautés qui aime qui ressort oui
mais le fait d'en parler c'est ce qui
aide aussi et c'est justement le thème
de cette semaine nationale de la
prévention du suicide c'est parler du
suicide sont des vies madame vaines
à ce propos cette semaine pour vous
c'est une semaine de nombreuses
activités
d'abord docteur volant parlait des
chiffres et je pense qu'il a raison des
chiffres sont très élevés dans les
communautés autochtones n'est ce pas
absolument la détresse et les présente
la souffrance est présente également
cette semaine de nombreuses communautés
se mobilisent et organisent des
activités spécifiques dans le cadre de
la semaine
pour sensibiliser les gens à parler être
en contact les uns les autres parler de
la souffrance c'est présent partout
exactement
alors parlons de ce que fait votre
organisme à vous justement pour
évidemment essayer de contrer les les
envies de suicide de beaucoup de gens
qu'est ce que vous faites
concrètement sur le terrain mais au
départ la c3 spn qu elle offre un
accompagnement prêt spécifique à
l'ensemble des intervenants qui
travaillent sur communauté premières
nations dans l'atteinte de le vers
l'atteinte de leurs objectifs au niveau
du mieux-être de la culture de
l'autodétermination et de la santé dans
mon rôle spécifique à la c3s ponctuelles
j'offre un soutien au niveau de la mise
en place des stratégies de prévention du
suicide
job de la formation présentement nous en
sommes à plus de 250 intervenants dans
l'ensemble des communautés au québec qui
ont été formés à travailler auprès de
leur population en prévention du suicide
dans l'intervention de crise d'accor
dont vous vous êtes installé à wayne
d'accueil alors finalement vous êtes le
haut de l'édifice là puis ensuite on
s'en va vers les communautés avec les
intervenants qui sont formés grâce à vos
services
exact d'accord alors on pourrait parler
également de la proche de la vision que
vous avez justement par rapport à tous
ces enjeux qui concernent évidemment
cela créera la prévention oui du suicide
cette année on a décidé d'axer nos
actions et la plupart des communautés
également vont vers l'optique de la
promotion de la vie qui est une approche
vraiment global pas uniquement travaillé
auprès de l'individu et de sa souffrance
mais également de l'ensemble la
communauté donc on veut aller voir les
forces quelles sont les forces déjà on
va aller chercher ce à travers la
culture à travers tout ce qui peut aller
rassembler les gens la quête de
l'identité aller chercher ses forces
c'est ce que vous disiez docteur n'est
ce pas la promotion de la vie promouvoir
la vie absolument parce que si on ne
gère que les crises pendant deux trois
semaines on envoie des forces spéciales
avec ma tactique pour aller régler ces
temps de crise la pression on oublie des
communautés pendant des mois et des mois
et il faut pas justement il faut
développer des forces comme madame veins
est des forces pour moisson de la santé
globale promotion de l'aide de la vie
parce que la vie c'est le plus beau
cadeau c'est souvent avec un constat le
matin c'est peut-être le cateau le plus
difficile parce que bon faut se lever il
faut les travailler il faut affronter le
froid il faut affronter les des épreuves
mais nos ancêtres l'ont fait et je pense
qu'il faut se rappeler de la force de la
résilience de nos enseignes en innu on
appelle chiffonné au chapeau n'est aussi
quelqu'un qui est fort qui capable
d'endurer la douleur la souffrance et
nos ancêtres étaient des gens très très
très courageux braves et qui ont réussi
à nous rendre jusqu'ici la preuve que
c'était des gens braves est résilié un
méchoui ici aujourd'hui et y est plus de
100000 autochtone qui veut au québec
c'est la preuve que nos ancêtres étaient
résilient et c'est résidentiel et
apporter l état une ou deux générations
c'est pas d'histoires anciennes c'est
pas l'histoire des liens non c'est
l'histoire d'une cinquantaire oui on a
ces jeunes lot de gens très régulière
mais là la colonisation les pensionnats
leu leu
le récit ce système est bouleversée ça
donc il faut reprendre séquelles telle
de nos enseignes et en faire quelque
chose de faim pc être fiers de célébrer
notre fierté notre culture notre langue
nonne douche ensemble et notre petit
toit ni comment on fait ça je pense que
c'est en faisant des programmes de
promotion de la vie de se dire tu sais
pas jusqu'où pas seulement prévenir la
maladie mentale mais nina maladies
physiques et spirituelles et une
approche globale et je pense que les
devoirs des gens sortir dehors de leur
facebook de l'ordinateur et d'aller
commencé à serrer la main de leurs
voisins parce que moi j'avais quand
j'étais jeune il y avait pas de facebook
les gens les rentrées la maison on sent
prêt et des lampes raid est importante
aujourd'hui on voit qu sauf dans nos
communautés les gens sont enfermés nadal
à deux malheurs facebook il devient
solitary s'isole et l' isolement nous
fait du mal
donc il faut apprendre à célébrer notre
communauté puis à célébrer le fait
d'être ensemble mamou ouvrir leur donnez
nous le monitoring moss est restée matic
très importante et mon grand père m'a
toujours dit mammuth in una nous faisons
ensemble survivent tas de bonnes crêpes
et nano est séparée mi moore on sait
bien que c'est très résilient résiliente
savaient que s'ils s'allient avec autres
chasseurs qu'ils survivent donc il faut
qu'on se remette ensemble oui et qu'on
brise ne tenant isolation le suicide
dans les communautés chez les
autochtones en général ils touchent plus
les as du tout les adolescents ça touche
toutes les couches même les adolescents
ça touche beaucoup aidé les saints on a
des chiffres des adultes qui sont très
très élevé et même chez les aînés des
chiffres qui commencent à apparaître
deux tentatives de suicides de
dépressions et même chez les très jeunes
et des cas de suicides chez les 8 9 ans
dans les dernières années dans nos
communautés dans les communautés inuit
aussi donc ça touche la côte toute la
couche
des cycles de vie des premières nations
oui donc peut pas juste focus et sur les
seins mais il faut fawkes et dès que la
baie que le bébé dans le ventre de sa
mère je pense qu'il faut partir de là
jusqu'à la fin de la vie et donc pour
moi c'est il faut changer nos
communautés
il faut que nos gammes qui sera prennent
en main soit fier d'eux et surtout
commence à s'entraîner oui madame ben tu
sais ce que vous voyez aussi dans les
groupes d'âge qui sont touchés par le
suicide
oui parce qu'évidemment elle vous
côtoyer les gens qui vont dans les
communautés qui travaillent pour vous
qui vont dans les communautés c'est ce
qu'on perçoit aussi
oui absolument et je voyage beaucoup sur
communauté j'ai quand même très présente
et sa touche tous les âges du jeune
adolescent aux personnes aînées mal
baboulin oui c'est ça comme le disait
docteur volant de plus en plus de
personnes aînées sont aussi touchés par
le fléau
absolument et surtout les gens les aînés
qui ont été aux pensionnats il ya des
statistiques canadiennes et québécoises
skis d'hommes qu'ils montraient que les
gens les ennemis qui avait été au
pensionnat un taux de dépression et de
suicide book plus élevé que ceux qui
n'avaient pas été au passionnant ce qui
se comprend tout à fait n'est-ce pas
ouais c'est 80 % des gens passionnants
était ont subi des sévices physiques
psychologiques sexuelles de tout genre
ces gens-là traîner un lot passée 1-1
l'aube à garges que est souvent le latex
comme annie l'alcool la drogue essaie
d'endormir et la drogue et l'alcool
finissent par briser le le la stabilité
ou le laisse là d'énergie mentale et
je sais mais la conséquence et j'ai déjà
lu ce que vous disiez sur l'alcool colts
qui ne fait qu' un problème qui a été
apporté dans les communautés les
autochtones ne buvaient pas d'alcool
n'avait pas ses problèmes de
consommation d'alcool déjà dans les
anciennes générations
c'est arrivé à l'arrivée des
colonisateurs mais rapidement l'alcool
était un moyen de faire du troc et aussi
pour alléger un peu le des gens entre
les îliens qui confronte la mort tous
les jours prendre l'alcool c'était comme
une façon de s'évader
une façon aussi lieu de façon historique
ethnologique l'alcool on recherche
beaucoup le rail 20 puis l'alcool père
permettait pas peut-être aux gens de
s'évader combinant cet espace lods et
s'apprêtent eux ce serait une émission
complète
oui alcoolisme mais ce n'est pas marc
aujourd'hui les effets de l'alcool il
peut être transformé en rêve en un
cauchemar
et aujourd'hui c'est poche décoller
c'est la polytoxicomanie qui est
omniprésente dans nos communautés
les speed les en vitamine d
tous les tout est accessible et
accessible se mélange il est un mélange
explosif pour les jeunes et pour toutes
les générations
oui alors madame veine dans votre
travail vous mettez en place des
programmes justement pour aider les gens
dans les communautés ya plusieurs
programmes qui ont été développés au fil
des années on pourrait en présenter
quelques-uns et savoir comment est-ce
qu'il fonctionne sur le terrain au
niveau des outils des pharmaciens ou à
quelle j'imagine qu'il ya de tout ça il
y ait des outils ad formelle bien sûr
oui la c3 spn qu elle accompagne
l'enfant des intervenants
neuf des services-conseils diverses
formations selon les besoins de la
clientèle et on va adapter les outils
culturellement sécuritaire pour les gens
sur communauté on a notre offre de
service est très très variés oui alors
j'ai vu entre autres le journal créatif
expliqué will qui est le journal créatif
à chaque année nous tentons de répondre
aux besoins des intervenants dans le
cadre de la semaine de prévention du
suicide et on a eu envie de développer
un outil qui vraiment va aller chercher
nos forces personnelles
on veut apprendre à se connaître on veut
que ça soit ludique agréable on veut pas
uniquement
focus sur les problèmes sur la maladie
comme l'a mentionné dr volant on voulait
que les gens aient un petit outil pour
voir ce qui les entoure
au niveau de la culture à quel point
leur culture est présente dans leur vie
qu'ils sont les gens importants autour
d'eux ce qu'ils ont des rêves
est-ce qu'ils ont des passions qu'ils
veulent cultiver c'est ce qu'on voulait
leur proposer un d'outils qui peut être
utilisé tout au long de l'année qui peut
être fait seul qui peut être fait en
famille avec un ami avec un intervenant
tout ça de façon agréable mais prendre
un temps de recul pour vraiment analyser
j'en suis oui si mendy bilan global donc
c'est ce qu'on propose cette année et
qui sait de plusieurs bars bardon qui
est adopté toutes les générations
évidemment au port de l'adolescence mais
ça peut très bien fait à l'âge adulte je
pense qu'on ne termine
amir d'apprendre à se connaître et de
prendre un petit temps de recul pour
évaluer quels sont nos objectifs pour la
prochaine année qui est autour de moi
quelle place dans ma culture dans ma vie
est-ce que je pratique des activités
traditionnelles est ce qu'il ya des
choses que je désire connaître plus
spécifiquement de ma culture cette année
que je veux investir donc c'est son
désir et proposer quelque chose de très
ludique et on est à plusieurs milliers
d'exemplaires présentement tous a été
envoyé dans l'ensemble des communautés
des milieux scolaire et une somme très
heureux de l'accueil que cet outil a
reçu il ya aussi des cartes de pensée
positive parce que c'est vrai que là
c'est ce dont on a le plus besoin une
pensée positive la pensée magique on
aimerait bien mais au moins ils
pensaient positive vous stanley quand
vous avez traversé ces moments
difficiles
comment avez vous réussi à retrouver une
pensée positive mais ça a été ça a été
très long
première des choses est de consulter un
conseiller professionnel ça a été ma
porte de sortie si pour moi qui m'a
beaucoup aidé pouvoir stabiliser et le
deuxième jour c'étaient le sport
l'activité physique est bon les
autochtones ou n'est pas des gens sont
les légendes action puis mais nos grands
parents aussi des démarcheurs des
canoteurs donc se retrouver dans la
soirée
c'est quelque chose qui ressource
énormément on a retrouvé deux trois
quatre jours il aller dans la forêt là
c'est qu'on dirait que la forêt me
redonne d'une énergie et quand je me
retrouve dans le milieu urbain tout le
monde vive voix les mon énergie quand
jean mon énergie très beau et là j'ai
des gens qui viennent prendre cette
énergie là mais dans la forêt non
personne prend en énergie la forêt me
donne cette énergie là vous nourrir elle
me nourrit on est des enfants de la
forêt oui j'suis des enfants la nature
et donc c'est une façon pour moi de
pouvoir me ressourcer et je pense que
dans nos communautés la foire est très
très proches
et c'est pas dans l'univers de
l'internet qu'on peut se ressourcer mais
plus dans la nature c'est vrai madame
veine je sais pas ce que vous avez on va
parler des cartes de pensées positives
mais on parlera aussi après ce que vous
avez ce genre d'activités qui oblige les
gens les jeunes tout le monde à sortir
et justement allait s'inspirer de ce que
la nature leur offre mais d'abord les
cartes de pensée positive c'est quoi
exactement
les cartes d'inspiration été créé dans
le cas de la journée mieux-être des
premières nations qui est le 1er février
de chaque année
donc c'est une autre activité ludique
qui nous avait été demandé donc on a
élaboré tout ça évidemment basé sur la
route médecine et les quatre fers pour
développer sur le côté holistique
donc nous avons dépensé qui adresse le
mental émotionnel le côté physique et le
côté spirituel de chacun donc des
petites cartes amusante qu'on peut piger
à tous les jours pour s'inspirer il se
recentrer et les gens les trouvent ou
ses cartes alors elles peuvent être
commandés sur le site internet de la c3
et spirituelle donc www.transilien.com
ils sont accessibles
vous avez vous pouvez les commander
c'est un problème d'accord là on parlait
de la nature est ce qu'il ya des
ressources comme ça est ce que dans les
communautés
on prend les gens directement sur place
et on leur offre justement la chance de
pouvoir sortir des fois d'un milieu qui
peut être extrêmement difficile ça peut
être ça être dans une maison où on vit
des choses extrêmement difficile et leur
donner la chance d'aller voir ailleurs
et voir où est ce que ça se passe mieux
finalement
mais de nombreuses communautés offre des
ressources mans en territoire donc
parfois pour des fins de semaine parfois
pour des beaucoup plus long séjour
c'est ce jour là peuvent être
accompagnés d'intervenants il ya des
aînés également il ya toute la
transmission de savoirs traditionnels
qui est fait dans ces moments là je
pense que c'est le moment qu'ils sont
grandement appréciés et désiré de la
part des gens de se retrouver en contact
avec la nature l'énergie avec qui nous
met chez nous docteur volant ça aussi
c'était un ressourcement pour les jeunes
qu'est ce que vous faisiez quand vous
arriviez dans les communautés et que
vous alliez vers ces jeunes là justement
pour les leur donner envie de plonger
dans d'en bas dans leur vie quotidienne
mais de voir qu'il ya des belles choses
et qui s'y trouvent
il y avait le niveau de l'événement il
va d'événements n'avait communauté ou
qu'elle les marcheurs arrivée et le
genre rencontrer les jeunes allemands
les écoles du primaire au secondaire et
où j'allais voir les jeunes pour la 3d
mon histoire de résilience mon histoire
que justin jeunes des pessimistes qui
parlait peu france a enregistré 7
injectant une tendue qu'à l'âge de 5-6
ans qui mes grands parents m'avaient
adopté que ça venait les chercher d'un
sud elle est devenue médecin me yves et
pire ça ressemble pas mal à mon histoire
j'ai trop aimé on y tient fort pour s'en
sortir
les quatre enfants de quatre pères
différents cc
je suis loin que je n'ai pas une famille
or vous mariez d'appui et mais beaucoup
de jeunes qui viennent qui me regardent
mais il y des choses que j'ai vécues ou
que je vis donc qui me donne l'espoir
que si je crois mes rêves et que j -p
que je perds
est ce que je percevais où je devrais
peut-être mais ils restent peu importe
mon rêve est de devenir un parent de
devenir un pompier de devenir chef de
mon village mon livre qu'elle rêve suis
inspiré john locke à force de marcher et
rdd obstacle c'est normal de tomber
c'est normal d'avoir des doutes c'est
normal de faire des détours parce que
souvent on tombe pile on s'arrête puis
on se décourage
mais mon grand paille est tombé
plusieurs fois dans la forêt mon gars
mais les remparts ont aussi mais ce sont
toujours relevé et je le redis ça moi je
tombe sur fois j'ai tombé
des fois c'est vraiment un mal quand
j'ai vraiment chez m dépression qui a
duré presque quatre ans sa durée montage
ont su relevé
vous êtes capable d'en faire autant et
dont je leur donne un message d'espoir
aux jeunes et aux moins jeunes et aussi
avec les gens avec qui je marche mais je
peux pas partager mes histoires leurs
histoires et et lorsqu'on pense du temps
date sous la tente le soir donc on
saisit ces histoires là on s'encourage
mutuellement
j'ai de mes amis qui étaient super de
faire une tentative de suicide qui est
venu marcher avec moi qu'ils devaient
marcher ça est ce que les maths avec moi
qui ne marchait 640 km et on a vu au
match mais ces princesses et à écrire
sur le mur était marquée à coeur
vaillant nul est impossible et c'est
devenu son leitmotiv qui a dit chetouane
abou dhabi
c'est quelqu'un qui vers bahia ne se
décourage jamais oui très joli très
inspirant en effet alors il ya des
communautés qui se prennent en main
aussi qu'ils n'attendent pas qu'on aille
vers elle mais qui décide un tout de
suite de battre le fer quand il est
chaud et c'est ce qui est arrivé au
nunavut est nichée une communauté qui a
décidé l d'implanter un projet créé par
la communauté pour les gens de la
communauté exactement soit en parle de
baker lake qui n'était déjà pas 1600
personnes nunavut et le mien xj de
projets le projet munich ce gîte été
mise en place en 89 et c'était suite aux
révélations des victimes d'abus sexuels
par une presse qui a travaillé dans deux
communautés dans les années 70 et les
années 80 oui et puis après que la
première personne à parler de ce qu'ils
ont vécu c'était vraiment une son ami
des autres victimes qui en a parlé il ya
les intervenantes de santé mentale qui
est venue de ce parce qu'il faut se
rappeler dans l'arctique on ne veut pas
de psychiatres conte plein dans nos
communautés un peu de médecins mais il
restait quelques semaines bien parti et
les crises que ça crie dans la
communauté
une femme qui se parle madame coup de
louvres pas que koudou maintenant elle
est la présidente
un prototype qui est l'organisation pour
les femmes inuites au canada met à la
porte qu'elle ait dit elle expliqué
qu'elle était tellement fâché de voir
tout le monde qu'ils aient besoin de
l'aide lui rien elle a commencé le
propre projet et de danser mais next gen
ça veut dire les gens qui s'occupaient
des eaux pour les gens qui protège les
eaux et l'idée c'était jumeler la terre
pays occidental avec les pratiques de la
thérapie 'new traditionnelle et d'avoir
ça ensemble dans l'intimité en
permanence et puis c'est maintenant ça
fait presque 30 ans que le projet est à
baker lake et de parler avec les
victimes les gens qui étaient en crise
le valeur qui a d'avoir un projet dans
la communauté pour la communauté est
vraiment extraordinaire
et qu'est ce qu'on y fait exactement
mais il ya toute une gamme de choses et
c'est comme
comme vous avez dit tantôt valence
c'était la question de la résilience et
de mettre l'axé sur ça c'est sûr il ya
un travailleur social qui est l'heure
pour les thérapies occidentale mais
c'est aussi de vraiment de parler de
résilience et les histoires des grands
chasseurs dans la communauté qui était
parti à la chasse que les difficultés et
des fois passé des semaines mais ils ont
servi et qui est vraiment vous connecter
les gens avec cette tradition de
résilience pour sortir de les
difficultés qui sont en train de vivre
mais aussi le chose qui est très
intéressant avec munich s'est dit aussi
c'est ils ont dans la communauté à tous
les activités sauts il veut vraiment que
tout le monde voit ce projet les gens
qui travaillent pour ce projet au les
événements communautaires aux réunions
municipales dans les écoles pour noël
est ce que l'idée c'est de bâtir la
relation chaque jour chaque semaine
alors quand une personne est en crise
il sait exactement où aller et la
relation n'ait déjà là parce qu'il faut
se rappeler encore au nunavut quand il
ya quelqu'un qui est en crise et surtout
dans les questions du suicide de se
rendre aux stations de celle ci est
déchiré besoins des économies le
psychiatre bien dans le iii - samarie
annoncé un sens
et puis de choses c'est comme c'est un
défi dans tout l'arctique depuis des
années mais ce qui est intéressant avec
munich s'est dit c'est que maintenant il
ya d'autres régions il est par exemple
en grande lande et les inuits de
tchoukotka en russie qui vient étudier
le projet magnifique pour voir s'il peut
répliquer ça dans leurs communautés
aussi c'est sûr c'est comme ils ont
passé le conseil d'administration s'est
tous les bénévoles ont alors tous
bénévolement ouais sauf les travailleur
social mais les conseils
d'administration dont clairement
l'implication et à tout le monde et puis
tout le monde ne cumulent télé c'est le
travailleur social
mais les gens qui travaillent dans
l'intimité comme avec les gens qui
sortent de prison
les politiciens il dit toujours là ce
qui est très important c'est qu'un
projet dans nos communautés ne peut
répondre aux besoins de la communauté et
créer des programmes en fonction des
besoins actuels parce que c'est
différent dans chaque minute
alors ça fait 30 ans que ça existe donc
il ya des résultats les résultats sont
probants est ce qu on a vu que le taux
de suicide avait diminué chez les gens
de la communauté
écoute il faut dire qu'il ya des comme
je dise les vagues
et puis on peut pas dire que les
pourcentages mais je peux dire que les
gens dans la communauté les gens qui ont
dit que les gens dit que cette programme
la sauver ma vie parce que si au milieu
de la nuit j'avais peu une reco appelé
mx gypse oui qu'est ce que j'aurais fait
celui comme les gens de la communauté
qui parle de leval ah oui oui oui madame
veine on l'a vu entre autres avec la
crise de suicides au nunavik et non pas
au nunavut
donc dans le nord du québec une énorme
crise du suicide qui a de la difficulté
d'ailleurs à se résorber
est-ce que vous en voyez bon je pense
que vous ne trouverez pas vous le
nunavik donc vous que non exactement
vous couvrez les premières nations
mais ce qui à ce genre de programme qui
a été créée par les communautés pour les
communautés à ce que vous savez de très
nombreuses comme noter on les programme
fait pour et par les premières nations
qui mélange les approche plus
traditionnelle et les approches
occidentale de nombreux indiens naturel
vont être intégrés dans plusieurs
activités des aînés également toujours
pour favoriser leur retour
à l'identité hors pair à la culture
c'est des programmes qui fonctionnent
très bien et qui rejoignent énormément
de gens beaucoup de programmes au niveau
des heures contes et légendes perlage au
niveau de la chasse et de la pêche
également où on va faire de
l'intervention mais on voit intégrer
toutes là la connaissance traditionnelle
à l'intérieur de ses activités le oui
est est ce que dans ces projets là dans
ces communautés on utilise justement les
outils vous avez mis à leur disposition
est ce que ça sert aussi dans les
communautés et dans ses différents
programmes savez-vous le site tout
nouveau on vient de faire nos envois
nous avons eu beaucoup de demandes pour
retourner
de nombreux exemples ans le message
qu'on associe oui on va utiliser à
l'intérieur de suivi personnel il ya
certaines personnes qu'on a ciblé à qui
on va l'offrir
oui en espérant que ça pouvait servir et
oui vous avez préparé une vidéo aussi ça
s'appelle on est là pour toi d'ailleurs
je pense qu'on va pouvoir en voir
quelques minutes ça va nous donner une
idée de ce que c'est mais avant qu'on le
voie expliqué nous un peu ce que c'est
l'année dernière
toujours dans le cadre de la semaine de
prévention du suicide de nous désirions
offrir un outil qui indiquera aux gens
que c'est important de parler c'est
important de se confier ce soit un ami à
un aîné à un intervenant aller chercher
de l'aide ne restez pas seul avec votre
souffrance
on est conscients qu'elle est là et
qu'elle existe mais elle ne restez pas
seul
et cette vidéo là on a plusieurs
représentants différentes nations à
l'intérieur différentes langues
également des messages qui sont lancés à
l'ensemble de la population nous avons
eu plus de 17000 visionnement sur
facebook est quand même un bon signe
pour l'ensemble des communautés donc on
était très très fier de ce produit mais
si vous voulez on va écouter quelques
secondes
cette vie
nous on est là pour toi parfois je me
sens seule triste
perdu incompris du prochain s'annoncent
disputées
comment s'est mis bien voir ce n'est pas
seul c'est important d'en parler en
notre nom
[Musique]
étonnant que je suis là pour toi à meyer
fuyu li je peux accompagner tous nos
sens noble fauga d'adieu à biaudos voilà
il s'est pas terminé ça dure presque
deux minutes on vous la nuit en français
en anglais et dans diverses langues
autochtones
absolument alors cette vidéo vidéo là
elle est déjà disponible elle a déjà été
lancé dès vous ayez déjà plusieurs
personnes l'ont vu absolument c'était le
lancement l'année dernière dans le cadre
de la semaine de prévention du suicide
mais elles peuvent être visionnées toute
l'année les messages d'espoir c'est bon
tout le temps oui c'est vrai message
d'espoir c'est bon tout le temps de la
prévention du suicide d'une semaine je
pensais être mais suffisant oui on
savait qu'un bus a même par amélie c'est
une
c'est un état qui touche les pros mais
nation à peu importe l'état de l'aide le
temps de l'année puis je pense qu'il
faudra être les provocations au suicide
soit à l'année longue
on faut que ce une semaine mais on
devrait une fois que c'est sur une année
complète bien sûr parce que le problème
ne dure pas qu'une semaine tous les
jours tous les jours le problème est là
dans la vie des gens rient le message
d'espoir doit être répété et répété
parce que quelqu'un qui a déjà subi de
la dépression est très sensible d'en
faire un autre ont défié on devient très
très sensée mais qu'un conte ont déjà
fait une dépression au devis plus
sensibles aux signaux qui nous amène à
dire jusqu'à je commence à aller mal
voshix train de soin de moi il faut
jamais consulté fou je m'ouvre aux
autres et je pense des messages d'espoir
des victimes et c'est à dire le soleil
finit toujours par se lever puis on va
t'accompagner comme un message qu'on
avait tantôt une très belle vidéo que
m'a fait beaucoup réagir je trouve ça
bien boucherie de façon très
émotionnelle puis donc c'est des petits
messages qui sont important d'entendre
tous les jours puis les gens se ferment
dépression les gens s'isole les gens se
renferme
il faut vraiment s'ouvrir et dépôts et
un message donne souvent aux gens qu'à
quelqu'un marche de cette grande loi sur
la et là pas besoin de se faire
sermonner
alors j'ai besoin d'une main mais qu'ils
le veulent accompagner au bout de la
nuit
quand j'ai franchi cette grande lula
j'étais content d'avoir quelqu'un qui
m'accompagnait et on a besoin de sa
campagne mal là et on a besoin de la
communauté pour sa compagnie oui le
messager
la communauté doit se mobiliser mais pas
juste une semaine par année mais 52
semaines par année
ensemble on va aller très très loin
vous êtes docteur volant comment allez
vous douze ans après avoir voulu enlever
votre vie comment allez vous douze ans
après ouais c'est ça va très bien j'ai
d'avoir deux jours c'est un peu déprimé
en deux jours mais est ce que vous
disiez on est toujours un peu
hypersensibles à fred cet automne j'ai
une petite bande son c'est toujours au
moins 9 en décembre
les gens des journées raccourcissent à
l'ange et la dépression pic à ce moment
là en novembre décembre au mois de
janvier février
le salaire vie on dirait qu'elle
d'énergie revient donc il faut que j'en
parle à chaque année puis mes cheveux et
leur faisant du sport en étant avec mes
amis mais ça m'arrive à moi ces réseaux
la détente hd aux gens je vais moins
bien et vous m'accompagner à vous
l'exprimez semestre est important il
exprime je l'exprimé pas il ya douze ans
aujourd'hui j'ai des mécanismes de
protection autour de moi j'ai quand même
je reconnais les signaux d'alarmé j'ai
des amis le sport qui met beaucoup la
marche à la nature dont je connais les
moyens ni les enfants la famille qui est
là autour du absolument mais je sais je
vais être très vite lassant de ma vie
donc c'est un message
une fois que le u soyez toujours allégué
oui madame veines c'est ça dr volant le
dit bien c'est pas une semaine nationale
de prévention c'est finlande de semaine
nationale de prévention donc cette
semaine particulièrement bon vous avez
donc ces activités vous avez lancé ces
outils mais qu'est ce que vous faites
les cinquante et une autre semaine de
l'année pour elle être là on appuie
écouter les gens dans les communautés
mais au niveau de mon organisation c'est
sûr que on a différents départements et
on aide à la création entre autres à
travers nos différents programmes
d'environnements favorables
tout au long de l'année je pense 365
jours par un livre vous parlez de
bien-être de mieux-être
d'autodétermination de culture comment
on fait pour avancer malgré les
difficultés dans le cadre de mon travail
de façon plus personnelle geof de la
formation j'accompagne les intervenants
je répondais question je les aide à
planifier leur stratégie tout au long de
l'année pour garder les gens le plus
possible en sécurité apprendre à se
parler lorsqu'on souffre d'un très
difficile d'aller chercher de l'aide
donc ça demande aux intervenants aux
gens de la communauté toute entière
d'être proactif afin d'aller vers
également les gens qui souffrent qui
vont pas bien de tendre la main
ça se fait tout au long de l'année je
crois c'est sûr que une semaine c'est
bien ça ça fait qu'on pendant une
semaine on va vraiment abordé le sujet
afin mais faut pas l'oublier le reste de
l'année
c'est très important alors je ne sais
pas depuis combien de temps vous
travaillez à la commission de la santé
et des services sociaux des premières
nations québec labrador
mais est-ce que vous avez vu des
changements positifs depuis le temps que
vous êtes là mais je vois des
intervenants très mobilisés je vois que
également c'est un sujet qui est
difficile c'est un sujet qui peut être
câble cependant les gens souffrent de
plus en plus et comprennent l'importance
de parler ne pas rester seul donc oui je
vois des améliorations des changements
tout n'est pas parfait mais je vois des
gens impliqués je vois des gens
résilient
je vois des gens qui ont à coeur le bien
être de leur communauté
oui docteur volant avez vous espoir vous
si vous voyez vous des changements quand
vous allez dans les communautés je vois
des changements je pense qu'une
amélioration certaine mais tranquille
c'est sûr que je me rappelle en
2009-2010 eu une grosse crise de sucden
obi wan si c'est dans dix neuf ou dix
suicides en 2 1 en louis dont un enfant
de 9 10 ans et pour moi c'était comme un
élément un événement très marquant jeudi
bon il faut faire de quoi
c'est à ce moment là j'ai commencé ma
marche j'arrive au bide jouanno en 2010
2011 puis la communauté venait de se
remettre de cette vague de suicides il y
en a encore au bide joigne à notre mode
des suicides en avoir encore des vagues
de suicides mais il faut être à l'affût
de ce donc
vous travaillez 52 semaines par année
moi de mon côté j'ai remis en marche une
nouvelle fondation qui s'appelle le
chemin des mille rêves où je veux
développer le plein potentiel des jeunes
de façon holistique leur plein potentiel
dans tous les domaines et aussi de
développer des avions en favorable c'est
un peu le but je me suis donné et mon
bâton ici symbolise le mont ballast en
2000 rêve qui en contient plus de 20000
m ça commence est acquis que sakic et
millions en 2013
plus de vingt mille jeunes ont déposé
leurs rêves dans ce bâton donc un bâton
d'espoir et j'espère un jour moi le
donner à un jeune qui donnerait espoirs
d'autres personnes parce que je
commençais à deux mètres cinquante trois
ans voir des jeunes qui vit qui
faiblissent et j'espère que d'autres
personnes prendront le bâton pour amener
cette nouvelle sage le d'espoir auprès
des jeunes qu'on a un grand potentiel
soyons fiable qui on est et ensemble on
va aller très très loin et luttons
contre la dépression contre le ccdh le
sud qui tue qui nous enlève d'écran
potentiel je connais des gens qui
avaient un gros potentiel qui ont décidé
de
de s'enlever la vie quelle gamme à jouer
quel gâchis pour l'associer à gauche
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai écoutez on va
tendre le bâton vers tous les gens qui
nous écoutent on va leur dire déposer
votre rêve sur se bat on voit les
recevoir et surtout prenez la parole à
parler exprimer vous parlez et d'amendés
l'aï pris parce que c'est pas ta boule
c'est si loin de la puce est pas une
faiblesse est souvent l'elysée mme
autochtone ne passeront pas parce qu'ils
veulent démontrer cette cet esprit le
masculin manque pas de l'ange kardon
débrouiller tout seul et les jeunes
hommes autochtones
malheureusement prennent souvent des
moyens biala pour s'enlever la vigne et
les femmes ou six ans les façons
différentes
donc s'ils gardent espoir le soleil
finit toujours par se lever
voilà c'est avec ce mot de la fin que
nous allons conclure cette émission ma
dérive n à québec merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à notre facebook live
aujourd'hui ni gouache et à très bientôt
mais rire beaucoup docteur volant très
gentil d'avoir accepté de témoigner de
participer à cette cette émission pour
pour nous dire que vous êtes là vous
êtes plus fort que jamais merci beaucoup
puis me gouache
merci maintenant merci et mccormick la
cour michel caron voile sur les langues
autochtones et merci à tous d'avoir été
encore une fois avec nous aujourd'hui
d'avoir participé à ce facebook live à
la semaine prochaine pour un autre
espace autochtone en direct au revoir
[Musique]